the two of you make a great team and
thanks to erectile dysfunction
medications he's always ready when the
mood is right and now you have help as
well introducing modulus the first
fda-approved female libido enhancer that
takes just two weeks to start working do
not take the jealous if you take
nitrates for chest pain as this may
cause an unsafe drop in blood pressure
do not drink alcohol in excess of the
jobs side effects may include headache
upset stomach delayed backache or muscle
ache if you have any sudden decrease or
loss of hearing or vision or have any
other degree options such as rash hives
swelling at the lips tongue throat
we're difficulty breathing or swallowing
stop taking the jelous immediately ask
your doctor about pajamas for daily use
and after just two weeks you'll know
it's time and the wait will have been
worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
it's great add okay
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]